and there he is baltimore's own bruce
zimmerman he is back after three months
on the il had some bicep tendonitis and
then a little bit of an accident in the
weight room sprained his ankle kept him
out even longer but back in baltimore
for hopefully two more starts so a
two-out walk to devers keeps the inning
alive for the red sox and that'll get
xander bogarts to the plate and he got
him down on strikes red sox retired in
the first orioles coming to bat no score
chris sale trying to go to 6-0 5-0 in
his seven starts since he joined the red
sox he's 8-0 against baltimore with a
2-16 era
yes down he goes
the breaking ball puts him away and
mullins swings and misses strike three
number one for chris sale this slider is
sweeping not even close that ball is two
feet outside ryan mount castle rookie
first baseman's had a big year
paul drilled in 95. he struck him out
admiring the pitch two down two down for
austin hayes round ball charged by the
third baseman devers throws on the move
and got him nicely on a close play
roughly got a good break and fired it
took it out of the glove and fired her
right over the top one down for
schwarber he's a 265 overall with 31
homers schwarber hits a long deep drive
center field backing up mullins all the
way to the wall leaping up and she's
gone kyle schwarber with number 32 and
he's delivered the red sox a one-nothing
advantage fly ball left the ballpark is
what that was when that ball went off
the bat i didn't think was out it's the
kind of power that schwarber has he hits
the ball high and just enough two down
for iglesias three and two the pitch
swing and a miss zimmerman put him away
on the chain jump mancini leading off
the bottom of the second sale struck out
two to begin the ball game
popped into center field and [ __ ] to
make the play and cine gone to begin the
second inning for chris sale and there's
a base hit so pedro severino the first
oriole base
runner of the night as he slaps one into
left field two quick outs for pat
valencia the shortstop and there's a
swing and a fly ball and a slider to
shallow right center rent throw to his
right this time hauls it in sales with a
quick and efficient inning despite the
hit after two one-nothing boston
chrysler comes home to jamai jones in
there for strike three as he sets down
jones
strikeout number three for chris sale
kelvin gutierrez draws a nine pitch walk
and he's the orioles second base runner
marlins next
he's gonna rope that one and go
a double play to end the inning dulbeck
got to the bag after making the grab
that was an absolute missile from
mullins but right at gulbeck and that's
how chris sale gets out of the inning
mount castle leading off bottom of the
fourth inning red sox had one of nothing
cut on and missed he strikes out mount
castle fourth punch out for chris and
there's one away here is austin hayes
hayes will swat at that he'll come up
empty he strikes out back-to-back case
from chris sale that slider looked like
it broke twice so a base runner with two
down severino singled in the second
there's a broken back comeback from sale
gloves it spins and throws software to
first inning over so much for that sale
works around the error and he's been
great tonight
five he's walked one
pitch count in good shape as he moves
into his fifth inning so one gun but
lake of the short stop to bat for
baltimore there's a fly ball to center
field shallow [ __ ] coming still coming
on dives forward and makes the catch he
dives straight ahead on a soft shallow
fly ball not all that high he got there
well never for a second did you think he
would not make that play lurching ahead
at the last moment to grab it well
there's the second out and it brings up
jamal jones takes a strike fastball at
the knees and down he goes and quickly
the orioles are retired six punch outs
for chris top of the sixth inning tight
one here socks with a one-nothing lead
as the plan will stay on to pitch
against renfro he'll crack that one to
right field that's well hit hayes is
back at the wall
and that's out of here home run on a red
throw it is 29 as he goes opposite field
to make it two to nothing got it up
there over that railing out there in
right field here camden yards chris sale
has been awesome through five innings he
has allowed one hit 2-1 gutierrez cracks
this one back up the middle the play at
short is not in time
xander bogarts had to charge into the
grass on a very soft hit ball from
kelvin gutierrez
gets the scoop and throw to first but
cannot beat out
the speedy third baseman for the o's
orioles with just their second hit
tonight off chris sale bring up ryan
mount castle 0 for two that's hammered
way back left field forget about it ryan
castle has tied this baby up
number 32
for perhaps the american league rookie
of the year he's making a statement you
gotta love to see it from this kid
kelvin gutierrez singles
mount castle drives him home a blast out
to left field
and we are tied
sales reaction with the home run oh that
just i'll tell you what that's as angry
as we've seen him so a 2-2 tie in the
sixth brings up hayes
there's another base hit lined into
center
right in front of hernandez
the big turn and austin hayes back to
first the hook is out well here comes
alex cora so that's all for chris sale
tonight pitching into the sixth inning
it's a 2-2 game chris sale knocked out
here in the sixth that's how robles will
take over him so runners at first and
second one out for pedro severino picked
up the first hit in the ball game
bounced to third and away from devers
around third hayes he'll score mancini
digging for third he's in the orioles
have taken the lead
not sure how they're going to score that
one ben but he hit it hard and the
orioles have the lead it's an rbi single
pedro severino orioles take a 3-2 lead
in the six orioles pitching has set down
seven in a row
bounced down to third gutierrez has it
two down two quick ground ball outs for
joey crable crable delivers and it's
popped up
right side
in a foul ground severino makes the
catch in front of the orioles dugout he
has another one two three inning so man
on for pedro severino has two hits
himself
and a turn on that diving play devers up
and gunning
and off the bag he pulled bobby d away
from first base so mancini safely down
to second roy devers makes a nice play
to get to this ball a little panic piece
once he gets to a nice play full
extension and he hurries up and his
throw is just off target asap puts him
on it first and second with two down and
mckenna will be the hitter
short right field can anybody get there
no they can't
mancini around third he'll score mckenna
hustles into second and the orioles at
another run and go up four to two
and now the red sox have to recover they
are down four to two gold salser has
pitched really well 279 era
and a fly ball in the left mckenna has
that sized up and that's one down sucks
two outs away from their fourth straight
loss and here's bogart pulled on the
ground at third gutierrez has got it at
his waist he tosses to first there's out
number two
two out and nobody on
[Applause]
and line drive at the left that's driven
back and a little bit by mckenna to end
the ball game on the warning track
and embracing himself against the wall
and the orioles beat the red sox in game
one four to two
nice play by mckenna to finish this off
doesn't get much better than that
ball bounces around in his glove and he
seems to holds on to it save for salsa
and the red sox managed only three hits
in the ball game against that oriole
pitching staff